what's up everyone we have the Rog Phone
7 Ultimate and as always Rog has killed
it with their clean futuristic packaging
before we get into the main box we got
to mention the devil case we got here
which was made with the Rog Phone 7
Ultimate in mind so the devil case has
excellent feedback it has anti-allowing
because it is a clear and glossy case
and also has double protection and is
impact resistant so this will come in
handy to protect your phone Rog has also
sent us an antibacterial screen
protector which we'll be using later on
so let's put it aside and just get
straight into the box it looks extremely
sleek and futuristic and it has a Delta
shape to it and oh this clamp is
magnetized and it just shows the phone I
think but there's definitely more to
this that meets the eye so we'll check
it out later on I know for sure Rog
loves doing this thing with their
packaging where it's interactive so
we'll get back to this later on okay so
let's just get straight into the main
box so let's open it up and there is a
another box inside with the Rog logo
let's see what's inside inside this one
and it's the phone case that comes with
the phone so if you don't have one at
launch at least RGS you covered and has
you protect it and now under that that
is the main phone it's a bit deep inside
the packaging let's just take it out and
oh it looks so Chic and clean all right
so let's just rip off the packaging and
look at how the pack looks like and yeah
that looks amazing look at the embossed
Rog logo at the bottom real quick it
feels really sleek and it feels damn
good in hand besides its Chic futuristic
looking design it also has its cameras
about four of them and you know it's
different parts so let's just put this
aside first and check out what else is
inside the box we have some cables
inside here they are USBC USBC we also
have a 65 watt charging head inside the
Box
at the top is oh yeah we have some more
stuff inside here looks like we have
what appears to be a pouch yeah so it is
a pouch and there's something in the
back as well so let's just take that out
I believe that is the aeroactive seven
cooler there shouldn't be anything else
inside the box so let's just check out
these two packs so we have the pouch for
the cooler and we have the air active 7
cooler inside this pack down here so it
is a very comprehensive package that we
have for the Rog Phone 7 Ultimate and
yeah the cooler fits in the pouch
perfectly we have the devil keys in hand
and we are going to be trying all the
cases so for the devil case it fits in
very snugly it's very sturdy in hand
yep it's hella solid now let's try the
one that comes to the box and you know
obviously this would fit in perfectly
but I think I might like this one a lot
more than the double keys and that's
because I can attach the aeroactive 7
cooler on while having my phone
protected so on the side there is a USBC
Port meant for the aeroactive cooler to
be attached on and that's why I love
this case because it was really made for
the air active cool to be clamped on
securely before we get into it this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stay around for the sponsored mess if
you're looking for a laptop that does it
all gaming streaming and content
creation then look no further than the
Rog surface M16 the first 16 inch laptop
with an anime Matrix LED array so you
can showcase your inner geek to the
World featuring a 16x10 aspect ratio QHD
Pantone validated Rog nebula display
this display not only looks great but
also offers unprecedented performance
thanks to its 240Hz refresh rate and
three milliseconds response time with
all that power because of full width
heatsink supported by Rog intelligent
cooling with tri-fan technology to keep
the laptop cool while intense gaming or
heavy workloads for more details check
out asus.com with that all the way let's
turn the phone on
also what we did find out about this
meant that the clap is that it has a
bigger role in the unboxing experience
with Armory crate so let's experience
that
hi X I have a mission for you I left
something at the maastrix space station
you should know where to find it it
might be a little dangerous so be
careful and good luck
so that magnetic flat that we got
earlier on that's called a cyberfly
panel we need to take it out and put it
flat as possible on the table and place
the phone on it alright so we're gonna
align it and it should connect all right
it's good
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
in essence these cyberflight panel acts
as an interactive controller of sorts
that connects to the phone and you'll be
pressing different buttons to activate
different things such as setting
destination and taking off the ship for
the mini game later on
foreign
Creed the cool thing that it does is
that it categorizes games based on their
supported refresh rates with ADD
triggers and we're going to be gaming
with this in our gaming test so if you
want to check that out you can check the
link in the top right on the console
page you can see the different modes and
measurements for temperature CPU usage
memory usage and so much more and you
can also access the different modes that
the phone has available for you such as
xmode plus Dynamic mode and Ultra
durable mode so now activating different
modes will affect your phone in
different ways so let's try X mode and
try hitting apply it will affect the
phone and how it looks like so let's
just do that as you can see the air
active cooler now has a different RGB
pattern according to the mode that you
have applied so going back to Dynamic
mode and applying it the air active
cooler doesn't have its RGB pattern
anymore let's remove the aeroactive
cooler for a bit and I oh I hope you saw
that the hatch was open so the hatch is
called the air active bottle which helps
to effectively cool the phone with the
air active cooler pretty interesting
features RG has put on this phone so far
we also have Rog Vision back on the Rog
Phone 7 Ultimate reminiscent of D6 Pro
you can change up the animations to the
ones you like that Rog currently has and
they'll flash beautifully on the P
AMOLED display on the back of the phone
and man this is just one cool ass
looking phone let's try out its main
camera it is a Sony 50 megapixel IMX 766
camera so if you look really closely you
would find that this camera is actually
pretty alright and it's pretty damn fast
you can get Ultra wide on the camera as
well and it has real-time Distortion
correction and you have a bunch of
options for Flash HDR and the video Call
of Duty goes up to like what 4K 60fps so
this is overall a huge improvement over
the Rog phone 6 already and of course
there is a selfie cam so here's that key
looking good wow
so cool
nice there we go now the beautiful
display has a refresh rate that can go
all the way up to 165 Hertz but only on
Dynamic mode and not on X mode because X
mode caps it off at 144 Hertz the game
genie on this lets you mark the refresh
rate the phone's performance and enable
do not disturb modes such as no calls or
no alerts on top of cooling modes and
control mapping there are a lot of
options that you can access by swiping
on the top left or top right corners of
the screen mapping air triggers is
pretty simple just enable it through the
game genie and Slide the right and left
trigger circles onto your desired
buttons
besides the air triggers there are even
buttons on the air active cooler that
you can map out with the phone there are
four more triggers the right and left
buttons and the right and left triggers
essentially you can combine the cooler
triggers together with the air triggers
to have six triggers in total it's
definitely going to take some getting
used to but once you do get a hang of it
you will tear the lobby up
so that's all there is for a quick
Hands-On impression of the Rog Phone 7
Ultimate if you have any questions about
it leave in the comment section below
and don't forget to like And subscribe
to our Channel it goes a long way don't
forget to follow us all of our socials
to keep up with the latest news we put
out you know what we've had a blast
playing with the RG Phone 7 Ultimate
with its air triggers and having its
cool on the back this has been an
amazing experience if you want more from
us check this out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]